Speaker 1: Let's try Robin from our house.
Speaker 2: Robin, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Where is our house?
Is that Australia?
Speaker 2: Now, that's in Denmark.
Speaker 1: Denmark.
OK.
Beautiful.
Speaker 2: Thanks for taking my call.
David, I enjoy your show very much.
Pleasure.
That's very, very interesting.
I'm a rather politically active myself in
Denmark on the left wing than I follow American
politics with interest in your shows.
Very interesting to listen to.
Thank you.
I was I was just wondering I'd love to hear
your opinion on something, which is one thing
I've noticed very much in the American political
discourse is sort of a lack of knowledge about
what's going on in the rest of the world.
Like it's and it seems to me to be a problem
on both sides of the political spectrum over
there of obviously the right wing is totally
oblivious about what's going on in the rest
of the world, especially when talking about
things like health care and the welfare state
and so on.
But we generally laugh at them very much over
here, I'm sorry to say.
But I've also noticed that sometimes on the
left, where we sometimes have this sort of
feeling the like.
Let me give you an example.
When when when you when you finally legalize
gay marriage in America, there was like a
huge demonstration like this is this is going
to be great for the whole world.
And we've had this for decades.
It's like, no, this isn't new.
I agree with you.
I agree.
Speaker 1: But yeah.
And to some degree, I mean, listen, I'm guilty
of this myself to some degree.
You know, I do a show mostly on American politics,
and that limits the amount of time that I
spend following the politics of other countries
other than Argentina, because I'm from there.
And so I follow the politics there somewhat
closely.
But, for example, you know, should I be more
informed about what's happening in Ethiopia
right now?
Absolutely.
I have I have a sense of what's going on.
And I've read a few articles, but I should
be more informed.
Should I be more informed about what's happening
in the Congo right now?
Yeah, there's no question about it.
And I think that there's one aspect of it
that I think is important to recognize, which
is it is natural that the world will follow
the news more of countries that are setting
some of the cultural lines of sort of like
global culture.
And in that sense, technologically and culturally,
the US is very important.
It's not singularly important.
So to some degree, it's logic and also because
of the size of the US, I understand why, for
example, folks in Denmark are probably better
informed about American politics than Americans,
about Danish politics.
Like to a degree that makes sense.
But I agree with you that that Americans are
under informed globally for sure.
Speaker 2: Yeah, just my point is mainly just
that it would be healthy because I believe
that, for example, most Danish people, obviously
not all because we've got loads of different
different political opinions there as well.
But most people would be able to say with
a certain extent of accuracy what most other
countries think of Denmark, for example.
Ah, but I don't get that feeling from Americans.
I don't get the feeling that like if I were
to ask an American, what do you think?
What do you what do you think?
What do you think the generally the idea of
unions in Spain, for example?
I don't think most Americans would really
know.
Speaker 1: Well, there's a couple of there's
a couple different things there.
I mean, number one, global opinion of the
US was very low during the Trump era, other
than Russia, I believe Turkey.
And there was one African country I forget
which which had sort of like an unusually
high favorability.
But most of the world was pretty disgusted
with the US under Trump.
Much of that reputation has recovered under
Biden.
And so part of it there's there's two things
there.
One is depending on whose president we elect
sometimes such wacky people, that opinion
of the US changes drastically up and down
around the world.
The second piece of it is there's lots of
Republicans who don't want to accept the reality
of global opinion of the US.
And so whether they know or don't know, they
certainly don't want to accept it.
Speaker 2: No, that's true, but it was very
interesting to get your opinion.
Thank you very much for taking my call.
My pleasure.
Speaker 1: So are you aware in Denmark, do
you live?
Is it possible to ask?
Speaker 2: Well, OK, this is the second largest
city in Denmark is on the eastern coast of
Jutland.
Wow.
Speaker 1: I've never been to that region.
I have only been to Copenhagen and some immediately
surrounding areas.
Loved it, absolutely loved it.
And in fact, when I was bicycling in Copenhagen,
a viewer of mine stopped me on the bike path
and said, I watch you from Denmark.
And we took a picture together.
It's on my Instagram now.
Speaker 2: I know I know several people who
know.
I mean, it is very interesting watching you.
You do have a very sort of it's a very objective.
You have a very nice it doesn't seem like
you're preaching, which is we appreciate that.
Speaker 1: And I appreciate your appreciation
of it.
Speaker 2: Thanks.
Thanks very
Speaker 1: much.
Appreciate.
Yeah.
Take care.
Very, very interesting call.
You are loving it.
Absolutely loving hearing from some of these
folks.
Let's go next to how about Zach from West
Virginia.
What's happening in West Virginia with Joe
Manchin?
Speaker 3: It was going on, David, how are
you?
Speaker 1: Can you hear me?
I can.
You're coming through pristine today.
Speaker 3: Oh, wonderful.
Yeah.
So my main question was, I actually had two
questions, that's fine.
One is it's kind of a vague question.
It's how just how historical do you think
the moment we're living in like this decade
in particular is?
Speaker 1: I have no idea whatsoever, and
that's one of those things where I could give
you some hot take on it, it would just be
a guess.
I really don't know.
We don't know that until we look back and
and kind of have more context.
I think that there's the potential for this
decade as an important inflection moment,
because in 2016, the US elected Trump and
we saw this slide globally to authoritarianism.
We now we may be getting out of that or we
may not.
And so I do think over the next 10 years,
we're going to see what are the following
50 maybe going to look like in terms of whether
this authoritarianism and wing nationalism
takes hold
or
it's rejected.
B